I'm embarrassed because I've been
talking to you over the years and like a
lot of people I say here he comes
Willem Dafoe and then I saw this old
tape and I believe the year is I think
it's 1975 76 1975 and it's a tape of you
as a young acting student and you're
saying your last name and take a look in
the matter of the legal inquiry into the
mental condition of John Kish lies Eric
Schneider William Dafoe you've let
everyone mispronounce your name for like
forty years we've all been saying Dafoe
and you've been just sitting there going
like no I won't say anything let's keep
it that way I was confused kid you were
a kid haha oh so you were wrong I was
wrong
I have my family pronounced it Dafoe the
other half pronounce that Dafoe but I
found that like you when you'd go to the
dentist or something you check in and
say William Dafoe I'm William de fer
they'd say okay Dave oh okay so you had
you ready to get rid of that flowed
better and in the end when I became an
actor it's a nicer sounding yeah it's
yeah Dave oh wait yes get me pay fo is
not as good as me - fo yeah that's very
good well let's not you exposed
something yes yeah that's my job my job
is to expose and humiliate well that's
all the time that's all the time we have
for you